sabías que eeuu es ya la mayor potencia
energética del planeta si así es a día
de hoy eeuu ha recobrado la posición de
mayor productor mundial de combustibles
fósiles ningún otro país ni siquiera
rusia o arabia saudí se acercan al
gigante norteamericano
disney toda esta revolución está
teniendo importantes consecuencias y
está cambiando la política del país en
este vídeo te lo contamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace apenas 8 años tan solo 8 años el
suministro de petróleo y gas natural
ocupaba un lugar muy destacado entre las
preocupaciones de eeuu sobre su futuro y
no penséis que era algo nuevo para nada
venía siendo dependiente del petróleo
extranjero desde hacía décadas
[Música]
ya detenido según la lista de regalo
explora preserva laura que negoció el
poder del bayern y one medio water
esto es de exploración está ubicado y
sólo pueden ser detenidos y the wind
star weekend general finance and place
en el google de forma anexión sesión y
fue del archivo del planeta la vamos de
frente en weekend
se resguardan se saben rasgo william
kvist production tratada de huevos en
sexto y mios según se decía entonces la
mismísima seguridad nacional dependía
mucho muchísimo de poder garantizar todo
el suministro de gas natural y petróleo
necesario para el poder económico e
industrial del país
y ojo porque esto no parecía una misión
precisamente sencilla por aquel entonces
amigos de visual político lo recordaréis
bien el mundo parecía enfrentarse al
inminente declive de los combustibles
fósiles fijaos sino lo que ocurría en
eeuu
desde principios de la década de los 70
las reservas de petróleo de eeuu se
reducían año tras año la producción se
había desplomado un 50 por ciento que se
dice pronto e incluso la producción de
gas natural también caía
en otras palabras eeuu estaba agotando a
toda velocidad sus recursos energéticos
y se exponía a depender de
suministradores que a ojos de los
responsables de la seguridad nacional
eran cómo decirlo poco fiables y es que
hablamos de países como arabia saudita
rusia o nigeria por ejemplo sin embargo
desde entonces las cosas han cambiado
bastante y como tantas otras veces los
pronósticos nunca se cumplieron y hoy
los tanques de almacenamiento de crudo a
lo largo y ancho del mundo están a
rebosar
[Música]
qué está ocurriendo veámoslo
el regreso de una potencia petrolera
en los últimos años eeuu ha vivido toda
una revolución energética en pocos años
la producción de petróleo casi se ha
duplicado y hoy las reservas que se
pueden explotar garantizan el suministro
por muchos años fijaos en este gráfico
del wall street journal nos muestra el
incremento de la producción de petróleo
en eeuu desde el año 2011
como os podéis imaginar que eeuu haya
casi duplicado su producción tiene mucho
que ver con la enorme caída que el
precio del petróleo ha registrado desde
y no sólo ha sido el petróleo podemos
decir que prácticamente lo mismo ha
ocurrido con el gas natural así que hoy
eeuu es el mayor productor mundial de
ambos recursos
el caso es que como podéis imaginar todo
esto tiene consecuencias en muchos
frentes diferentes
pero qué ha ocurrido para que se
produzca semejante explosión
pues como muchos sabéis todo este cambio
se ha debido a una evolución tecnológica
conocida como fracking una tecnología
que aunque se conoce desde hace décadas
no ha sido viable económicamente hasta
hace relativamente poco tiempo
[Música]
antes de nada el fracking es una técnica
muy controvertida y de momento solo se
utiliza para producir petróleo a gran
escala en cuatro países eeuu canadá
rusia y argentina
al final del vídeo y también en la
descripción os he dejado un enlace donde
podéis ver cómo funciona en su defensa
hay que decir que muchos de sus
problemas tienen que ver con que es una
tecnología relativamente nueva a medida
que se va utilizando y desarrollando su
impacto se está reduciendo en cualquier
caso ese es un tema que trataremos otro
día en este vídeo nos vamos a centrar en
sus consecuencias económicas y también
políticas
alimentando el motor económico
amigos el renacer petrolero de eeuu ha
tenido mucho que ver en la recuperación
económica de este país en los últimos
años por un lado las importaciones de
petróleo de eeuu se han reducido
bastante y claro siguiendo la ley de
oferta y demanda toda esta oferta
adicional de petróleo ha provocado que
los precios bajen así que eeuu importa
menos petróleo y este es mucho más
barato y como sabéis petróleo más barato
supone gasolina más barata
pues bien se calcula que sólo por este
efecto los consumidores estadounidenses
se ahorran 150.000 millones de dólares
al año dinero que por supuesto se
utiliza para consumir otros productos
para montar negocios para prestarlos
etcétera etcétera
pero cuidado porque aquí no acaba todo
ni de lejos petróleo y gas más barato
favorece también a la industria
especialmente a una a la que además de
utilizar energía utiliza estos dos
recursos como materia prima me refiero a
la industria petroquímica la que por
ejemplo produce el plástico o el pvc
entre otras muchas cosas
[Música]
pues bien la combinación de mucho
petróleo disponible garantía de
suministro y bajos precios está
impulsando un boom industrial en el
sector petroquímico de eeuu atentos a
las magnitudes porque son de aúpa
el sector petroquímico está
desarrollando proyectos por valor de 185
mil millones de dólares sólo en eeuu en
este tipo de proyectos representaron
casi el 50 por ciento de toda la
inversión industrial en el país todas
estas inversiones convertirán a eeuu en
un gran exportador de plásticos
ojo amigos para que os hagáis una idea
se espera que en pocos años las
exportaciones netas de productos
petroquímicos como plásticos pero
también fertilizantes o disolventes
superen los atentos 110 mil millones de
dólares al año esto es casi tanto como
todo el petróleo que exporta arabia
saudita tienes que pellizcar te a veces
y decir esto es la envidia del mundo
desde luego está claro que semejante
negocio ayudará mucho a reducir el
déficit comercial de eeuu ese del que
tanto se queja a nuestro amigo donald
trump pero esperad un momento porque aún
queda más
en diciembre de 2015 como ya no era una
prioridad en materia de seguridad
nacional el congreso de eeuu levantó la
prohibición que existía sobre la
exportación de gas natural y petróleo
pues bien eeuu está a punto de
convertirse en un exportador neto de gas
natural y además está previsto que en
2017 venda de media un millón de
barriles de petróleo al día sí sí como
lo escucháis se duplican las
exportaciones de petróleo de eeuu
redefiniendo los grandes mercados
globales a ver eeuu aunque mucho menos
que antes sigue comprando petróleo del
extranjero pero en este negocio muchos
países por diferentes motivos como por
ejemplo para mejorar la seguridad
energética diversificando sus fuentes
están dispuestos a pagar una prima y las
empresas de eeuu se aprovechan de ello
pero sin duda alguna donde más se nota
es en el gas hasta hace poco transportar
el gas era algo difícil y se necesitaban
enormes gasoductos pero ahora gracias a
la tecnología del gas natural liquado se
transporta prácticamente como el
petróleo en grandes barcos
el gas así suministrado supone ya casi
la mitad de todo el mercado mundial sí
sí la mitad y aquí las empresas
estadounidenses están en primera línea
se estima que eeuu será uno de los tres
mayores productores de gas del mundo
para 2020
- importaciones exportaciones de gas
reflorecimiento la industria me parece
amigos que a los eeuu eso del
proteccionismo de donald trump le pilla
como decirlo en mal momento
y esperado un segundo porque esta
revolución energética también tiene
consecuencias políticas
[Música]
un salto diplomático
no se puede entender la política
internacional de eeuu en los últimos
años sin prestar atención al impacto que
ha tenido esta revolución energética me
explico hasta ahora como el suministro
de petróleo era una prioridad de la
seguridad nacional oriente medio y los
países productores jugaban un papel muy
relevante en la agenda estadounidense
pero el nuevo empuje petrolero de eeuu
ha hecho que las prioridades de la
seguridad nacional cambien y con ellas
la política exterior que ahora puede por
ejemplo centrarse en asia una tierra que
como bien sabéis los suscriptores de
visual política es la gran mina de
oportunidades
tales así amigos que si no hubiese sido
por este cambio de prioridades
probablemente obama nunca hubiese
decidido retirar las tropas de irak
probablemente la situación en yemen
libia o siria hubiese sido diferente
también pero digámoslo alto y claro todo
esto del petróleo árabe y la política
del golfo ya no es tan importante para
eeuu que incluso se da el lujo de
impulsar la llamada otan árabe que viene
a ser algo así como vale os encargáis de
vuestra seguridad y nosotros solamente
os echamos una mano por eso de no correr
el riesgo de crear una crisis mundial
por supuesto esta mayor independencia
energética también le da a washington la
oportunidad de ser más exigente con las
petromonarquías del golfo pérsico por
ejemplo en materia de derechos humanos
que aproveche o no esa oportunidad ya
depende de la estrategia política de
cada gobierno
por cierto si algo está claro aquí es
que con trump en la casa blanca la
apuesta por el fracking va a ser total y
es que el nuevo presidente quiere
continuar el trabajo de obama pero
metiendo la quinta eliminando cualquier
obstáculo que pueda haber por el camino
[Música]
primero la energía americana
donald trump lo tiene claro meridiano lo
prometió en la campaña y lo ha reiterado
con palabras y hecho desde que ocupa el
despacho oval su prioridad es dar vía
libre al desarrollo petrolero y gasista
entre otras cosas ha prometido eliminar
muchas de las normas y controles
aprobados por obama que podrían frenar
esta actividad trump amigos de visual
político quiere que el petróleo barato y
abundante sea el ingrediente principal
de su receta política y dicho y hecho
porque trump se ha rodeado en los
puestos clave de gente bastante
vinculada al petróleo
como secretario de estado- trump apostó
por rex tillerson que antes era el
mismísimo ceo de la exxonmobil
al frente del departamento de energía
está rick perry una persona muy ligada
al sector del petróleo y que fue
gobernador de texas el estado petrolero
por excelencia
y para rematar la faena al frente de la
agencia de protección ambiental está
scott pruett ex procurador general de
oklahoma otro estado petrolero y también
con buenas relaciones con el sector
en fin esta es la particular revolución
que está viviendo eeuu una revolución
que ha hecho saltar por los aires todo
el poder de la opep
como toda novedad tecnológica es
evidente que el fracking tiene riesgos
pero también es evidente que es una
tecnología que ha llegado para quedarse
y está provocando muchas cosas buenas y
que a medida que se desarrolle será más
segura eso sí hasta que llegue ese
momento estamos de acuerdo en que los
controles medioambientales son
imprescindibles
y ahora tu turno crees que esta
revolución energética de eeuu será el
comienzo de una nueva era donde el
petróleo será barato puedes dejarnos tu
opinión en los comentarios y también en
esta encuesta si te ha gustado el vídeo
dale a like y asegúrate de estar
suscrito al canal para estar al tanto de
todas nuestras novedades por cierto en
este vídeo te contamos más cosas sobre
el mundo del petróleo y la opep un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
américa